And I get 0.0217, which is a really small thing.
And the way I get there is what taking home times the probability of rain at home
normalizing it using the same number of a year plus the calculation for the same
probability of being gone is 0.6 times the rain I've been gone has a probability of 0.3
and that results is 0.0217 or the better of 2%--did you get this?
If so, you now understand something that's really interesting.
You're able to look at a hidden variable,
understand how a test can give you information back
about this hidden variable and that's really cool
because it allows you to apply the same scheme
to great many practical problems in the world--congratulations!
In our next unit, which is optional, I like you to program all of this so you can try the same thing
in an actual program interface and writes software that implements things such as Bayes rule.
But not to worry, this is optional.
If you don't know how to program just skip the next unit.